The beard is gone,
the hair was gone.
The coffee on the Tuesday is right here.
Why not?
So maybe you heard this story in the
news.
The UN Population Fund says the world is
about to add.
It's 7000000000th person.
The UN says the world's population will
reach a milestone.
This Monday,
7 billion.
Pete,
the world's population will hit 7
billion,
7 billion,
7 billion come Halloween.
There will be so many of us on earth
that it's actually kind of scary.
It appears that the good old human races
now 7 billion strong,
that's nine zero,
133 times around the world counted in
step 200 years to count aloud.
Starting from one,
two,
three,
four.
I did it.
So most of what I write is science
fiction and the reason I love sciflies
because I believe that talking about our
future is the best way today to talk
about our president.
Whereas in the past,
the best way to talk about our person
was talking about our past.
Put it this way.
If the rate of technological evolution
being so fast,
our actions today directly implicate the
situation tomorrow.
The president.
So close to our future that it's like
the shingles on the roof of the house.
Years,
days.
Moments almost overlap.
Each science fiction can explore this
intimate relationship anywhere from the
gutter to the very top all the time.
Warning that if the structure isn't
sound,
the roof will collapse.
When I tell people my right side fire,
I get the same question again and again.
What happens when there are too many
people?
What happens when the world becomes
overpopulated?
Well,
it's a good question and one I tried to
address in my first long fiction novella
called big city.
I put the link to that whole book online
for your pleasure.
You can find it in the doodly do,
but let's return to the idea of
population growth.
If you want to know anything about this
subject,
you have to start with Thomas Malthus
and his book.
An essay on the principle of population
was mount.
This is idea that humans are the only
animal on earth that increases its
population beyond its available
resources.
Basically,
we grow faster than we create food.
That leaves us with a whole hell of a
lot of people who are underfed and
malnourished.
According to Malthus,
humanity grows exponentially.
Nothing,
not even the plague or two world wars
can put so much as a blip in that graph
in the year 1800,
we were 1,000,000,200
years later and we're 7 billion.
Obviously we can't keep growing forever,
so eventually we're going to hit an
asymptote and level out what scientists
have a very hard time agreeing on what
that number will be.
Yes,
it's range from 10 billion to 20 billion
years.
What we do now during the agricultural
and industrial revolutions,
the life expectancy of children
increased dramatically between 1730 and
18.
Ten percentage of children who died
before the age of five decreased from 74
point five to 31 point eight.
Advances in medicine like compulsory
vaccination had increased the life
expectancy from 38 and 18,
50 to 78 in 2011.
The population growth rate hated speed
during the 19 sixties baby boom and just
over two percent ridiculously high.
Some people started to freak out like
Paul Albert,
you predicted in his 19,
68 book the population bomb that we were
headed for severe worldwide.
Fortunately,
early was wrong.
Innovation stepped in and saved the day,
and in this case innovation,
his name was Norman Burlap,
more than half the farmers of the world
living the subsistence agriculture
outside of the economies of their own
country.
They have had very little or no money
with which to make purchases of the many
items that you need for a decent life,
for is the father of the green
revolution initiatives to develop higher
yield crops using synthetic fertilizers
and hybrid ice.
The Nobel Committee estimated that in
1970 by the time he received the prize,
he had saved a billion lives.
Don't you just feel like shit in his
acceptance speech,
he said there can be no permanent
progress in the battle against hunger
until the agencies that fight for
increased food production and those that
flight for population control unite in a
common efforts.
Through that the growth rate has been
falling ever since the baby boom and
chances already won't reach that rate
ever again.
But consider this diagram,
well,
birth rates in the developed world
decrease and level out around one point
seven children per woman in Subsaharan,
Africa.
The rate remains at five or more,
or take a look at the distribution of
ages in the developed and undeveloped
world.
Look at how many children there are in
the letter.
Subsaharan Africa is also where we see
the most poverty and malnourished.
Clearly there is a connection between
fertility rate and quality of lives.
It tells us that a large part of the
problem concerning population growth can
be addressed by the empowerment of
women.
Okay.
That's Joel Cohen,
mathematical biologist and author of
educating all children a global agenda,
saying that not only is nutrition a
vital part of balancing population
growth in hunger,
but also the use of contraception and
most importantly education.
You can find the link to his Amazon page
in the dubliner.
I want to make one final point on
population growth and I'll have malthus
helped me out.
Again,
I believe that it is the intention of
the creator that Earth should be
replenished,
but certainly with a healthy virtuous
and happy population,
not an unhealthy vicious and miserable
one and if and endeavoring to obey the
command to increase and multiply we
people at only with beings of this
latter description and suffer
accordingly.
We have no right to impeach the justice
of the command,
but only our rational emotive executing
the justice of the committee.
Here.
He's talking about God's desire for us
to multiply and grow.
Of course that's fully.
There is no god.
There is no question that as a species
and like every other species on earth,
we had the innate desire to procreate.
Part of it is evolutionary,
but the question must be is all of the
evolution.
Do you want to have kids because you
want to ensure the future survival of
the human race?
Or do you want them for other reasons?
Social reasons,
because it's strange not to or personal
reasons because you crave a specific
kind of love because you want to be
needed.
Even secret reason secret to yourself
because you know that you will die and
there's no escaping it in one way to
ease the pain of is to know that someone
will remember you and tell about you and
in that you achieve a kind of
immortality.
Humanity can outgrow its evolutionary
instructions.
By the time you die.
How many times do you think you'll have
had sex to procreate and how many times
just for pleasure?
Advances in medicine will allow us to
live longer just as we jumped from 38 to
78 and 150 years.
Advances in technology will not only
allow our world to be energy
independent,
but ourselves.
Imagine getting all this sustenance you
need from the sun.
Imagine living to the age of 200 when
you'll really be able to count to 7
billion.
Maybe it seems out there too,
but evolution like population is
exponential and when we can live as long
as we want,
what will happen to our desire to
procreate,
to have children?
There is no easy way to answer this
question,
but I do my best to try in a second long
fiction,
a novel called all languages.
The rows coming soon.